großer militär aufmarsch am mittwoch auf
der unteren mariahilfer straße in wien
militärmusik und gardesoldaten bestimmen
das straßenbild und soldaten des
jagdkommandos sein sich spektakulär vom
dach ab und das alles wegen ihm der neue
checkpoint wird feierlich eröffnet was
das bundesheer mit einem shop auf einer
der größten wiener einkaufsstraßen
ansprüche
was wollen wir noch wir wollen
denn ab sofort kann sich hier jeder über
die vielfältigen betätigungsfelder beim
österreichischen bundesheer informieren
zum beispiel bildet das heer aktuell
lehrlinge in über 36 lehrberufen aus
so gut wie möglich präsentieren
und dann haben wir natürlich auch einige
der neue checkpoint mai auf der
mariahilfer straße 22 bis 24
[Musik]
der shop des bundesheeres ist eröffnet
[Applaus]